[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه صالونه اليوم يتحدث عن موضوع
يتراوحو بين الادب والتاريخ لكنه بالحقيقه
يخدم التاريخ او غرضه هدفه التاريخ ببساطه
الشعر الشعبي الذي هو جزء من الادب الشعبي
ما هو دوره في الاضاءه على التاريخ
الجزيره العربيه خاصه في مراحلها المبكره
المراحل المبكره نتكلم عن تاريخ الدوله
السعوديه لانه يلحظ بعض الباحثين كما
سياتي معنا في السياق ان الشعر الشعبي لم
يكن مزدهرا في عهود في عهد الدوله
السعوديه الاولى التي امتدت زها 80 عاما
لكن هناك من يرى عكس ذلك ويرى انه بمزيد
من البحث سنقع على ما يخدمنا في هذا
العطار الاطار والغرضوا ليس فقط التمتع
مباهج هذا الشعر
بالتعرف اكثر على تاريخنا وعلى تحولاتنا
وعلى عاداتنا الا ان الشعر كما قال
الاوائل هو ديوان العرب للاضاءه على هذا
الامر والتحدث في يشاركنا النقاش في هذا
اليوم الباحث السعودي سعد الحافي وهو باحث
مهتم
بالتاريخ المحلي وبالشعر الشعبي وله في
ذلك قصبه السابق وله همم جهود تشكر فتذكر
فحياك الله استاذ سعد في هذه الندوه الله
يسلمكم
هل الشعر الشعبي والاطلاع عليه ضروري لفهم
التاريخ المحلي
الجزيره العربيه
كان يغيب عنها التدوين في فترات زمنيه
سابقه
او انها تقريبا تمتد الى الف سنه تقريبا
اهملت في هذا الجانب لكن الشعر جاري على
لسان اهل الجزيره العربيه والشعر كان هو
الوسيله الاعلاميه والوثيقه التاريخيه
الداله على حياه المجتمع في تلك الفتره
حيث ان القصائد تحتوي على دلالات
وتحمل رؤى معينه وتعكس حياه اجتماعيه او
سياسيه جرت على اهل هذه الجزيره العربيه
ولذلك هي مهمه وكنز اغفل في فترات زمنيه
سابقه بنظر له على ان الشعر عام
وهذه يعني تعتقد انه انه الباحثين يمكن
بعض الاكاديميين ممكن حتى الباحثين غير
السعوديين ما اهتموا بهذا الامر مثل
الباحثين غير السعوديين اهتم نفهم يعني
لانهم لا يستطيعون تذوق او فهم مغازي هذه
الابيات وخلفياتها واجواءها لكن بعض
الباحثين السعوديين خلينا نقول ما هو موقف
الرواد يعني الشيخ محمد ياسر بن خميس
الرواد الاوائل بلاي هند بن العبود الله
يرحمهم جميعا وحتى الشعر الجنوب هل كانوا
على موقف واحد من الافاده من الشعر الشعبي
تتفاوت مواقفهم وتقريبا لم يتم همم الغوص
في النصوص الشعريه باستخراج دلالاتها
الكامله او تحقيقها وانما كان همم
تعاملهم تقريبا تعامل سطحي مع اراد النص
كما هو همم لكن لما تبحث في النصوص وتنظر
الى العمق في نصوص همم عندنا طلعناها لها
600 سنه 700 سنه 400 سنه فهذه لها دلالات
معينه وكان ان الناس ترى انه اقصى حد
للنصوص الشعريه العاميه يعني 200 سنه ولكن
بالبحث والتحقيق
ومقارنه بين المخطوطات طلعنا بكثير
تستعد انت همم فزت في جائزه الملك سلمان
للتاريخ حول همم الدور الشعر الشعبي او
الشعر الشعبي في تاريخ الدوله السعوديه
تاريخ الدوله السعوديه الاولى والثانيه من
خلال الشعر الشعبي والشعر العامي يمكن
الدوله الثانيه الناس تقول لك برز فيها
شعراء معروفين سواء من عيال الامراء
الاعيان الباديه والحاضره او من بقيه فئات
الناس لكن الدوله الاولى كانه الشعر فيها
نادر او قليلت يعني يمكن هذا لبث الحديث
اليوم يعني نعم لا موجود فيها الدوله
الاولى تمتد من عام اا يعني اذا قلنا 24
همم
اماره الامام محمد
يعني الى عدد سقوطها 1818
وفي نصوص شعريه كثيره وفي انا اعطيك كم
مجمله الان في من خلال البحث خرجنا تقريبا
25 85 شاعر
و140 نص همم لها دلالات عظيمه في احداث
معينه اغفل عنها اغفلت من جانب الموثقين
في كتب التاريخ
وتؤيد بعض القرائن اللي وردت في المصادر
التاريخيه مثلا مثلا عندك همم قصيده همم
الامير مشاري بن عبد الرحمن في حصار
الدرعيه وفي تحديد همم
الفتره الزمنيه في حصار الدرعيه وفي
المقاومه المقاومه فيها الغذاء العثمانيين
في الدرعيه هذه مهمه لم يتطرق لها احد قبل
كذا ولما تعطيك الدلاله هذه في النص سنه
تناول اذا كان همم
الامير عبد الرحمن مشاري بن عبد الرحمن
يقول يا ونتي ونت خلوج القطينه ونيتها
والناس ما هم دارين
جنه اللي طوحت بالحنينه حريمنا يوم
الركايب تجازين هنا يذكر ايش ترحيل الاسره
الى مصر نعم يومجله عن دارهم منتحينا جل
العذارى جضه تحرق العين عن دارنا العوجا
المصري انجالينا وعدونا لحقل منا
والملاعين عند دارنا العوجه دلاله لان
الدرعيه وطلاق اسم العوجه يدل على الدرعيه
لا يدل على غيرها
وانهم تم اجلاهم الى مصر يا الله يا اللي
له الشدايد رجينا تجعل مطاليع الليالي على
الزين في الرجل من همه خفيه الونينه لانام
خال البال الريس صورتين عليك يا دارنا
بعزك نشينا مرضى العذارى لابسات السباهيين
يا دار يا ما بك خزينه وجينا وما له
المعادي
اي عن كانوا ما يفعلون في الدرعيه
المهم يقول يا دار يا مال المجالس بنينا
ومنادم بين الرجاله التجاريين يا دار ياما
بكن سر الخدين لما عزه تلهى تكبوت
المعادين يا دار يا ما نلطم العايلين
انثار بطراف قدام المعادين
فزعاتنا اللي مثل ورد القطينه لباسه
بالكون زين التوامين 200 يوم وزودهن 40
يعني 240 ايام الحصار
العمر ما نتبع الليل يعني صابرين على
المقاومه والدفاع باستفسار عن الدرعيه نار
العميل
وظلوا المستحيله يعني اللي فيه همم خلى
عنهم هذه الصراحه قصيده رائعه يمكن هذا
سبب بروز شخصيه الامير مشاري والقصيده
الشهيره اللي ارسلها خاله والامام تركي
يعني غير نص ال- الشيخ
العمراني
كان مقرب من الامام لكن تتميز انها ذكرت
النهضه العمرانيه والنهضه التعليميه
والنهضه الاقتصاديه التي كانت تعيشها
الدرعيه هل لك ان تطلعنا على نموذج من هذا
الامر الاشاره للنهضه العلميه وذكر اسماء
الاشخاص اللي من الاسره حلو برده في نفس
النصف لكن القصيده يمكن همم
ولا تسوي قلت باسواقها اخر رقمها ولكن
عذرا كالغزال تليه ولا سامرت فيها جروب
الضيافهم ولا حاسبت فيها التجار بضيع ولا
حط فيها قبل هذا قيصريه ولا موسم فيها
العقول تضيع موسم التجاره
ولا مسجد
احد طلعها من المخطوط هذا
وتناولتها بتحقيق معين
وهي قصيده ذا الدلاله عظيمه
الجانب الاخر ان الشعر العام من ناحيه
المؤرخي اغلبهم لا يعرف اسباب لا يصبر
اغوار القصيده وانما يكتفي اذا كان اشاره
هناك ان هذه القصيده قيلت في هذا يكتفي
بعرضها فقط اما درستها وتحقيقها واستخراج
دلالاتها فلم يتطرق لها الى قراءه تاريخيه
واجتماعيه للنصوص الشعبيه وليست مجرد
قراءه للتذوق الادبي او المباحه او يعني
للاستدلال على حادثه الجزئيه بدون نظره
الكليه
في بعض ابحاثك
استاذ سعد لان هذا يحتاج الى توسع سنرجع
الى هذه النقطه همم كيف منهجتك في التعامل
مع الشعر الشعبي في العهود في فعاصل وجيز
لا تذهب بعيدا عن هذه الجلسه الماتعه بين
همم دهاليز الشعر والتاريخ
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد حديثنا كان ومازال
الشعر الشعبي ودوره في الاضاءه على
التاريخ السعودي سواء التاريخ السياسي او
الاجتماعى
وضيفنا وشريكنا للنقاش في هذا الامر
والاضاءه عليه الباحث السعودي سعد الحافي
وباحث مختص الحقيقه بالامرين يعني
بالتاريخ وبالشعر الشعبي وله في يعني مثلا
هو همم
له اشراف وتاليف ايضا على مسروع كبير جدا
اللي هو موسوعه الملك عبد العزيز في الشعر
الشعبي كم مجلد
تم تسليمه سبع مجلدات سبع مجلدات يعني كل
ما قيل عن الملك عبد العزيز هذا مشروع
قامت فيه اداره الملك عبد العزيز قسم قسم
الشعر العام فلما قدم المشروع كان
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين ايام كان
امير الرياض عن الشعر موسوعه الملك عبد
العزيز في الشعر العربي قال اضيف لها
الشعر الشعبي لانه هو القريب من الاحداث
والمهم
الملك سلمان وهو صاحب البصر او البصيره
التاريخيه في قيمه الشعر
قبل الفاصل همم ما هي المنهجيه التي
تتعامل بها مع هذا مع هذه الماده العلميه
وتوظيفها في البحث العلمي همم منهجيه
علميه بحته من ناحيه المسح المصادر واخذ
كافه الروايات وبعدين عرضها على همم محكه
التحقيق والمقارنه بين الروايات وقرنها
بالدلالات التاريخيه الاخرى
وكذلك في جان مهم السياقه المعنوي للنص
لانه في كثير من النصوص ادخل عليها ما ليس
فيها منحوله منحوله
وحتى انه يعني الكثير من الابيات اللي
دخلت على النصوص بغرض معين او نتيجه تشابه
بعض النصوص مع النصوص لو هذه قيدنا سعد
يعني بعض الناس يقولوا في القصائد اللي
تتشابه وزنا وتتشابه قافيه ويمكن بعض
الاغراض في يمكن تفهم ان تتدخل النصوص
خاصه ما في توثيق علمي اذا الروايه شفويه
في الغالب يعني الا بعض المخطوطات القليله
يعني اللي كانت موجوده في خزائن بعض
الامراء او بعض العليات القوم يعني هذا
يعني خلينا نقول لجانب العفوي المؤسف طبعا
المفروض يكون فيه لكن هل في جانب متعمد
لتحريف او اضافه او تزيف بعض الابيات
بعض الجهات الخارجيه في نصوص معين هو اقرب
دليل قصيده تنسب الى حميدان الشويعر او
الى قرينيس
راعي الحريق
نشات الدوله السعوديه الاولى وذكر احداث
معينه انتصار
الامام عبد العزيز بن محمد بن سعود في
معركه ثرمداء وغيرها اشارات معينه ولكن
ادخل في نصوص اخرى ابيات همم مسيئه على
همم
الانسان حميدان
والخطا الاخر نفس الابيات دخلت على النص
اخر نسب القرينيس لانه تشابههم في نفس
الاسلوب الشعري
وما زال همم يزيدون في الابيات هذه لحد
قريب يعني الى الان وهي زادتوني عليها
ويعدلون الشيء هذا طيب هذا يقودنا ايضا
الى موضوع اخر انا من دون ذكر اسماء بعض
المراكز التي نشات مؤخرا تقول عن نفسها
تهتم بتاريخ الجزيره العربيه من خارج
السعوديه
همم علمي بريء نعم بل باغراض اخرى اللي
تعرف الماده التاريخيه تجيش احيانا صحيح
خاصه انها تحتل جزء من الذاكره
في عام
1431 قال فيها الشيخ هذا انه صيانه تراثنا
ثقافي من العبث
لانها نجد مثلا في جهات دول اخرى همم ربما
تكون شقيقه
يمارسون همم حريه كامله في التعاطي في
تراثنا الادبي بما يتناف همم يتعارض مع
الوحده الوطنيه واثاره انهارات او
التزوير والتزهير وفق اهداف معينه وكان
المفترض ان همم كنت مقترح فيها المقال هذا
انه يرقد تعامل مع التراث الثقافي الى
مستوى رسمي من وزاره الثقافه وزاره
الخارجيه انه يعتبر شان داخلي لا يتم
تناوله من اي دوله اخرى الا باذن من
الجهات المعنيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واخذ الاذن لان هذا يخصنا ما هو
يخص
نجد بعض الباحثين يتجنب التطرق الى تراثه
ثقافي او ما فيه من نتوءات معينه ولكنه
يجد انه شيء مباح له ان يتناول بحريه
كامله وتطبع الكتب او تصدر همم الفيديوهات
او المسلسلات في اليوتيوب
انت مالك سلطان عليها ناس موجودين بره
سواء عندهم نوايا مبيت سياسيه او والله
حابب تعرف السوق السعودي سوق كبير حابب
يشتهر في السوق السعودي
يعني بما ان الناس تهتم بتاريخها هذول
اللي بره ما علينا منه انا ربه الابل
والبيت ربنا يحميك كما قيل يعني احنا احنا
كسعوديين هل تعتقد ان احنا لدينا تقصير في
الاهتمام العلمي في هذه ماده ال- ال- ال-
ال- ماده الادب الشعبي ان كان شعرا او
مرويات وسواليف كما يقال يعني
المنهج يعني اول قبل لا تناول هذا يجب ان
تتولى وزاره الثقافه مسؤوليهتها ما نترك
الاخرين نرقد تعامل معهم من انه شان داخلي
ويفهمونا هذا الحساب بنضع حد لهذا التجاوز
اما من ناحيتنا هنا المراكز الثقافيه همم
والاهتمام وهمم من وزاره الثقافه برضه انا
احط المسؤوليه امام وزاره الثقافه
اهتمت بكل شيء واهملت الجانب الادب الشعبي
الان عندنا انا اتكلم لك اني حققت خلال
الفتره الزمنيه من القرن الخامس الهجري
والرابع الهجري الى همم القرن الثاني عشر
الهجري ما يفوق 700 مقال نشرته الرياض او
في مجلات علميه اخرى
عندي كم هائل من المخطوطات ومن النتائج
اللي يجب ان يحفظ ويراعى سواء كنت بهانه
ويقوم به جهه مسؤوله تعطي هذا الاهتمام لا
يهمل لانه تركه همم هكذا اول شيء معرض
للتزييف معرض ان للتوظيف للتوظيف الاخر
ثاني شيء اذا كنا قادرين على ان نتعاطى مع
خلافه هذه بعد سنوات ما في احد يقدر
يتعاطى معه
فانا ما زلت من ذو المقال السابق اللي قبل
يمكن همم 1431 الان وطالب واكرر مطالبه في
ان يجب ان تقوم وزاره الثقافه بهذا الجانب
المهم
توثيق الادب همم دراسه وتحقيق النصوص
الشعريه اللي تهتم بحياه اهل جزيره العرب
هل في جهود مؤسسيه عندنا في همم في البلد
يعني نعرف في جهود الباحثين سواء الاوائل
زي مثلا ابن خميس همم اللي هم دونوا
النعده بالشعبي وغيره من مدير الفهيد
وغيرهم او اللي درسوه بشكل اكاديمي زي سعد
الصويان يعني يوظفوه بس هذه تظل جهود
فرديه يعني جهود باحثين هل في مؤسسات
معنيه بهذا الامر همم من قبل سيبك من قبل
تاليف وزاره الثقافه لان حديثه وزاره حديث
فيه اداره الملك عبد العزيز واتجاهها الان
حسب توجيه خادم الحرمين الشريفين طول عمره
في وضع همم قسم همم الشعر العام في موسوعه
الملك عبد العزيز الشعر العربي هذه خطوه
رائده
لكنها ما وجدنا اخرى الان وضع اني همم
تولى موضوع تاريخ الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والثاني من خلال الشعر همم العامه برده
خطوه اخرى لكن احنا نبيه في اطار رسمي
مستمر ما هو ان يكون باحثه دوره لا يجب ان
يكون مرجعيه كامله وفي اي نصوص وفي اجازه
النصوص وفي التعاطي مع هذه
شوي بعيد شوي عن عن هذا المحور لكنه في
نفس الجو
اشهر تاريخ
تم تداوله محلين تاريخ ابن بشر نعم تاريخ
ابن بشر لا نجد فيه نصوص عاميه كثيره الا
يعني شذارات نادره يعني وهو كان هو يصرح
انه يعني ان هذا اللسان الملحون او اللسان
العام او كبر هل هذا سبب انه تهميش هذه
الماده العلميه او الماده التاريخيه هي
كانت ظاهره عامه عند المؤرخين لانهم يرون
الشعر هذا ان لا يرقى الى مستوى انه يدور
عندهم وهذه انا انظر لها اسمح لي على
النظاره هذه لانه اشباح العلماء لان هذا
ثقافه المجتمع اللي انت تتعاصره والعامل
الناس همم هذا همم شعرهم فالمفترض انك
تتعامل معه كما يتعامل معه ابن خلدون ابن
خلدون تعامل معه في القرن الثامن الهجري
ودافع عنه قال هذا هو الشعر القصير لم
يختلف عن الا بالضوابط النحويه ولا ينتقد
الا من اعتقد الملكه ملكه همم التذوق
الشعر
فيها من هذا السبب اهمل الشعر انا وجدت في
مخطوطات في مثلا في دول اخرى وثقت الشعر
العامه ويخص الجزيره العربيه واستفدت منه
طلعت منه شعارا لم يكن معروفين هنا بس
واعطتني اضاءات معينه
وعكسه ابعاد معينه للحياه الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه في الجزيره العربيه في فترات
زمنيه اخر سؤال عندي من خلال رحلتك
المديده هذه
ومعايشهتك العميقه للشعر الشعبي وتقليبك
لاوراقه ومعانيه
عندي سؤال بسيط
شعر شعر العامي في الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والعهد الباقي معروف الثانيه هلا ما
استفيد من خلال خلجات الشعراء ومشاعرهم
واحاسيسهم ذلك الاحساس بفقدان الامن في
الجزيره العربيه وانهم يعني حينما يمدحون
الدرعيه او يمدحونا حاكمه حاكمه البلاد يا
دحونا ايضا في منجز الامن
خلال التوافق في هذا الشهر النصوص هذه
اللي فيها همم الاحتفاء نشاه الدوله
السعوديه الاولى في فرض الامن وهمم وتامين
الناس وشعرهم بالاستقرار
فكان متطلب اجتماعي تحقق لهم همم
الامام محمد بن سعود ومن بعد الائمه حتى
عهد قريب الملك عبد العزيز اذا هو شعور
عام شعور عام عكسه الشعر جميعا النصوص
تقريبا
الاشارات والتضامين هذه هذه المعاني
الساميه لعل يمكن احنا لان وقتنا قارب على
النفاذ فلعلك تنتقي من هذه من هذه النصوص
الانبياء التي تدل على فقدان الامن
وتتحثنا فيها في مقال سابق او في حاله
سابقه ان شاء الله
لاحقا وليست سابقا انا شديد شكرا لك
الاستاذ سعد
الباحث والموثق والمحقق والشاعر ايضا في
الادب الشعبي والذي له همم مزيده عنايه
واهتماما وتحقيق فيه كما اشكركم مشاهدينا
الكرام على كرامه متابعتكم في هذا التطوى
في الوجيز بين الشعر والادب والتاريخ
المحلي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]